so the big news today was that LeBron
James's 18 year old son suffered a
cardiac suffered Cardiac Arrest while
while practicing and instantly on
Twitter vaccine begins trending and
everybody is beginning to debate that
conversation or have that conversation
with people on the left saying like oh
it's a conspiracy theory it's not true
and people on the right of course saying
it's time to have that talk so uh we're
going to talk about him with LeBron
James I really want to talk about
experimental medicine because I recently
went and got some technically
experimental medicine myself and there's
some interesting conversation to have
there we also have a bunch of other uh
really interesting stories it was um
Joe Biden I guess he accidentally said
that we cured cancer or something he
muttered We've Ended cancer as we know
it and uh you know it's a big problem
when your president mistakes Syria for
Libya during military meetings or
publicly declares We've Ended cancer as
we know it when we we have not but
that's the present what do you expect
and then we've got uh some other
interesting interesting stories Rhonda
Santos has fired a campaign staffer who
retweeted
a video that had the black sun in it a
Nazi symbol so okay we'll talk about
that one sure fine whatever but ladies
and gentlemen before we get started I
have big news go to castbrew.com and
check it out we've got new new flavors
so of course you can get the Appalachian
nights Colombian French roast everything
you know and love but boom there it is
Mr bocus pumpkin spice experience now
available unwoke decaf light roast and
sleepy Joe decaf dark roast so if you
want some sleepy Joe it's there we also
have stand your grounds a medium roast
and uh we had of course all the other
flavors you know and love Colombian uh
everything Mr boca's pumpkin spice
experience in ground and whole bean
they're all available in ground and
whole bean so we double them up and you
can join the cast Brew Coffee Club you
get three bags per month so you get a
bit of a discount and it's available in
a mix of ground or whole bean choose it
if you go to casper.com and buy our
products you're supporting us we sponsor
ourselves so we greatly appreciate your
support but don't forget to also head
over to timgas.com click join us become
a member because we're going to have a
members only show coming up for you at
about 10 p.m where you as audience
members actually get to call in and talk
to us oh God you've got to be oh it's
gonna be fun you've got to be a member
for at least six months or sign up at
the 25 per month level and Michael calm
down it's screened by our team and then
we choose four or five individuals to
call and ask questions so if you want to
call in that's going to be a good time
and become a member at timcast.com now
uh of course you could already tell that
Michael Mouse is joining us tonight hi
everybody and he's sitting here he
ordered pizza you ordered pizza
I'd like to have a pizza party and we
said how do you think you want Michael
while you're here it's you know my home
is your home thank you so much who are
you hi I'm Michael malice I am really
excited to be back here my new books the
white pill white pillbook.com
um yeah I it's been a minute uh since
our last we all had that big together
get together in Austin where Alex um
kind of make it a little go off the rail
so I thought oh right let's have another
reunion have a little bit sedate and I
had a surprise guest with me and the
surprise got a little bit ruined but I'm
ecstatic how's it ruined I was I was
sitting downstairs at the poker table in
Roseanne Barr walks in no the the whole
point was she was I was supposed to
introduce her on air it was good I have
this whole fantasy in my head but yeah
the The Legend icon uh and someone who
I'm kind of surreal that I'm friends
with this person and takes my calls
Roseanne Barr is here hi
good pizza huh really good I don't I
don't think you need to introduce
yourself you can if you'd like to hi era
and producer she used to be on The View
then she hosted the Rosie O'Donnell show
for several years
I'm happy to be here I came to uh learn
from you oh you want me to go over here
yeah grab the mics people can hear you
you told me not to eat on the mic well
you're talking just swallow the pizza
and then oh okay
yeah I wanted to see how you do because
I'm doing a podcast now Roseanne uh
bar.com on YouTube and all the usual
places so I wanted to watch how you do
you're living large on this podcast
stuff I love it yeah I'm gonna learn
from you oh I appreciate it yeah I'll
we'll tell you we'll tell you anything
you want to know about a yard full of
chickens that looks good we have too
many chickens we got more there's babies
in there and they're having they make
more of themselves is the thing you know
I mean you just leave them in there and
you come back and there's more and
you're like oh how many eggs a day
you're getting
30 maybe good yeah it's a lot of
chickens this is the top story it's huge
news chicken city is overpopulated it
smells bad oh yeah yeah that's all that
ammonia and if it doesn't mess up there
isn't mess up their feet too no they're
fine it's not that overpopular it rains
and stuff and they have the outdoor area
but uh well thank you for joining us
gonna be it's gonna be really fun I'm
glad you're here I'm glad I'm here too
thanks for inviting me I am I I'm
delighted to make stuff like this this
is just in all seriousness one of the
people ask me a lot of times as many
people know I was a lifelong New Yorker
I've lived in Austin now for two years I
am now know how to drive a car I'm
getting lessons from Colin Robb who's
professional race car driver and uh it's
a little Overkill National indoor
skydiving Champion follow him on
Instagram Colin
c-o-l-i-n-robb underscore on Instagram
great dude well and I'm filming it
because I thought be funny so now I'm at
the level of like Asian female in terms
of my driving skills I can get around
step on it but the thing I miss people
ask me do you miss New York do you miss
New York what I missed about New York is
that when you go to a party some get
together you're going to run into cool
people who are doing awesome things and
that kind of vanished but that's
happening now in Austin so to be able to
like sit in a room and here comes
Roseanne Barr it's just completely
surreal I got on right I gotta hand it
to you man because it's your big part of
that it's amazing how you can just
manifest you put your mind to it before
you even move down there you're like I'm
gonna set up a house where a lot of I
don't know you didn't say intelligent
people it is but it's like it's like a
kind of a Nexus erudite you know people
that enjoy art and and reading and
things like information man I went to a
party at Michael malice's house and I
highly recommend if anyone is down there
in Austin and you know Michael that is
the place to be it was a lot of fun very
excited to meet the people you know
Roseanne you're one of them I love you
all right also also joining us is Phil
Levante how you doing I am philibonti
lead singer of all the remains
anti-communist and kind of revolutionary
I am excited to be here hi Roseanne I'm
so happy to be here miss Barr I am
uh Mr Mouse I really enjoy your company
when you're not pointing your closet we
are my favorite people uh we are uh
we're ready to go so what's up Ian's of
course here yeah I gave a little Sly
intro a little bit before Phil sorry
about that homie no they don't apologize
well I don't really have anything to
bring other than what I already did I'm
just glad you guys are here man and I'm
gonna point out to the audience that you
missed some gold because watching Ian
and Roseanne talk about UFOs before we
start yeah we gotta UFO story okay yeah
you're talking about power sources yeah
we're gonna talk about UFOs because
apparently some uh former government
intelligence guy came out and said that
the US has off-earth technology I am so
freaking lucky that I get to see all
this
all right we also got Kellen mashing all
the buttons yeah I'm filling in again
for search tonight what's up everybody
I'm Kellen Ian I love to see your exes
today you're really X and like crazy
it's always good to see it and I'll X
hard knock on I'm gonna so you guys know
Twitter is rebranded now so everyone's
been Xing hopefully keep their due
diligence all right why isn't it
expressing
Express Express right I mean just I
think X is dumb I don't care what they
call it expresses its two syllables and
you need like one syllable word for it
all right I don't know why I changed it
I went and got this tattoo on my arm
about three years ago it's the Twitter
bird you know oh yeah I said well this I
said well someday real quick this was
three years ago I said some people are
gonna own Twitter because I could see it
coming you know now I now this is no
damn good I gotta put an X yeah even
better yeah well let's uh let's let's
jump into the news before we do smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the share with your
friends and of course become a member at
timcast.com for the app.com for the
after show here's the Here's the the big
story this is crazy it's from uh Yahoo
Ronnie James LeBron James's 18 year old
son suffered Cardiac Arrest here's what
you need you need to know uh I mean
that's basically the story he was on the
he was he was practicing he had a car he
had a cardiac uh he had Cardiac Arrest
he was rushed to the hospital it was
very serious us he's in stable condition
he survived the big news however 18. oh
my God the big news outside of that is
that uh Elon Brown here here's the Daily
Mail bronnie James Cardiac Arrest is
linked to the covid-19 vaccine Elon Musk
suggests saying we cannot ascribe
everything to the vaccine but by the
same token we cannot ascribe nothing
musk wrote myocarditis is a known side
effect the only question is whether it
is rare or common musk's tweet continued
I will just say this as I always start
videos like this talk to your doctor
about what's right for you find trusted
medical professionals a lot of people
don't trust the medical system but there
are people out there who are good
medical professionals you can trust just
do the work and uh the CDC says it it is
rare myocarditis but I wonder what you
guys think about this whole thing can I
say one thing one it seems to me I'm
gonna put my tin foil hat on with this
issue it seems to me that one of the big
stresses where their demand was to get
everyone as vaccinated as possible was
to socialize risk because if everyone's
invested and if bad things start to
happen where we're all in this together
whereas if you have one population and
that population has consequences then
it's like okay it's happening to them
it's now there's going to be uh hell to
pay now it's like okay wait wait you
guys screwed up you know people in
Florida you guys screwed up maybe young
people whatever if it's everybody then
it's kind of like you can't it's like
that's how Corporate corporate systems
work bureaucracies work if you
distribute um the consequences then
really no one's to blame but but here's
but that also created the perception of
risk itself so I'll say a few things the
CDC says that myocarditis is a rare side
effect from uh the MRNA vaccine
specifically this is the CDC saying it
don't take my word for it and
myocarditis is listed as a cause uh uh
sometimes a cause of cardiac arrest in
young athletic males
that would easily mean that sometimes
people get the coveted vaccine may
suffer myocarditis and that may result
in Cardiac Arrest I believe it's
extremely rare however we gave out as of
October that was the latest number I
could find 630 at 37 or some some
ridiculous number of vaccine doses you
give out that many let's say it's one in
a million people who will get
myocarditis you're gonna have 600 and
some odd cases of myocarditis then
you're going to hear a bunch of stories
in the news and people are going to
assume many stories means it's happening
all the time when actually the same
percentage of people are suffering a
rare side effects yeah but you know
if you really were going to have some
trust and statistics you would have
hoped they would have used a control
group in the quote-unquote science which
they didn't so we don't really know how
many people we and plus I don't trust
their numbers anyway well but I think
that what happened to him is that global
warming got him oh yes but that's
another point or white supremacy no hold
on both very big issues but where where
are they at it was 120 degrees in Las
Vegas so uh he used to so hot right his
heart was going crazy pumping the heat
actually in all seriousness this in all
seriousness though when you're really
hot your heart pumps your blood like
crazy to move the heat through your body
so but it was hot and then he saw some
dudes from Saudi Arabia in the in the
traditional garb thought it was KKK
members had a heart attack we're all
joking no but if you've ever been in
that Las Vegas heat I mean I about had
myocarditis when I was there like about
five years ago just walking outside to
the cab yeah but you were a senior
citizen you know what I mean he's like
an 18 year old athlete so but the other
thing is this why they're being
disingenuous is they're saying it's rare
death from covet is rare it was like one
person even if it's one if something
happens to one percent of the people
that's rare one percent murder I think
America is 330 million people and
there's like 20 000 murders so that's
statistically irrelevant it's rare but
are we going to pretend murder doesn't
matter so that word is kind of a weasel
word uh it could mean what you're saying
or it could mean that it's doubling what
it should have been but that's still
rare and we should when it comes to the
CDC though one thing that I find
interesting and you know I wear a
permanent tinfoil hat you know that baby
because I'm 70 I don't believe anything
anybody tells me but uh you know the
permanent thing they say is to really
check out what these Undertakers are
saying how the death rate went up in
what population for The Undertakers know
it and uh they say it's through the roof
of people you know and insurance
companies say it too their stuff went up
a hundred and you know million points I
don't be coveted but I don't believe no
it's people dying
uh from myocard
here's the thing I don't believe that
five years ago that there were enough
news articles of young athletes getting
myocarditis and possibly dying I don't
think this was a thing all over the all
over the place on soccer fields and
South that's what I'm saying but I'm
saying five years if they're they're
trying to make it out this has none of
the vaccines I don't think and it's just
we're just noticing it now I don't think
there would have been enough to notice
here's my here's my question why why is
the immediate assumption it's vaccines
and not that it was covered we so we
know that myocarditis covet does cause
myocarditis okay uh and we know that
that's true it was the alpha the alpha
stream was brutal it was super brutal
and then over time as it started to
mutate it became less and less serious
the very strange Omicron whatever so the
first trains were were nuts so you know
all these we see these documentaries
like um what was that one where the
they're pulling the clots out of the
body oh yeah but but suddenly I died
suddenly I saw that and I said
could kovid be doing this and the weird
thing to me about it is you've got this
conspiracy theory and I'm not saying
that to be disparaging to people who
don't trust big Pharma the idea being
that there is these vaccines may be
causing blood clots they call it the
clutch on stuff like that and I'm like
here's a conspiracy theory covid was
manufactured through gain of function
research doc fauci funded it it was made
in the lab it leaked and is causing
extreme reactions that we're seeing
which results in blood clots and
myocarditis true what about that
conspiracy theory right right I mean
that could accept that one that's what
I'm saying I mean I I think also to your
point it's kind of telling that you're
now in a position to make that question
on on air and not have be shut down
completely and totally now there's two
possibilities one people push back
enough they're like okay or that there's
enough data that what you're just asking
about can no longer just be pretended to
be just tin foil hat nonsense no it's
proven it's fact this one thing that a
lot of a lot of the Liberals brought up
encounter to you know vaccine starts
trending when bronnie James has this
news breaks and a bunch of Liberals are
like hey covid causes myocarditis and it
does and it did like well before the
vaccines we were seeing it I don't know
if there's enough news I don't feel like
it would cause it in young people and
young athletes if it might cause it in
someone who's older and weaker already
but like if the whole thing with covet
is it's not targeting young people and
in fact children don't know that though
well we know the terms of the death
rates and things like that well but
death rate's not the same as as
transmission I could see like I read a
study that said that a lot of uh infants
uh you know that are born dead I can't
remember the word for it stillborn
stillborn they have heart
issues in you know for money yeah so we
don't know if that's that the mother had
covet or that she I was talking about it
either yeah I had count dankula in my
show and he was talking about the rates
of stillbirth uh miscarriage in Scotland
was like through the roof yeah
I'm just saying but the thing is it's
not nothing right so the whole point is
that absolutely the argument is this
isn't really happening or just noticing
it it just because you can't think of
the cause doesn't mean the consequence
is not occurring but it should be open
to it exactly you know discussing and
like using scientific method rather than
getting in big fist fights over it's
this or that we should be open to
finding out what the hell is and I don't
think it's a partisan issue like people
are dying it's not I mean this is
nothing to do with Reports look look but
they make everything into a partisan
fight Democrat Governors put coveted
patients in nursing homes and killed
elderly people they were born they
killed the old people definitely aquoma
was warned explicitly right the Javits
Center and the Comfort were available
for housing sick people and he was like
I put them in nursing homes and they
said if you do that elderly people will
contract covert they will die he did it
anyway
he must have done a calculated risk like
if we don't do it this many people could
die if we do it unless people Javits
Center yeah it wasn't even at capacity
it was it was they converted into
hospital I I I and you know that they
that I've heard this I I don't know that
it's back but I've seen it reported as
fact that uh hospitals did get a payoff
for every death yes yes that's true
he was 26. here's here's what I want to
say about you know uh we have we have
this debate over like DeSantis and Trump
and this conversation comes up and
people often point to you know Trump was
buddy buddy with fauci and Trump did
Operation warp speed and I I just want
to say you know look I like experimental
medicine a lot Trump was in favor of
right to try right it's a good thing
government mandates are a bad thing
right corporations mandating people
getting medication and the government
through circuitous methods or direct
methods forcing it is the problem yeah
Trump funding whatever I'm like if I
don't if I'm not forced anything I I
don't really care right I mean fine
whatever I don't like the big
Pharmaceutical massive multinational
corporations
but I recently just went to Tijuana and
got experimental medication to treat my
my damaged tip and it helped me out
greatly but I chose it so yeah I don't
like the you know my view is not to rag
on Trump because he funded experiments
it's to rag on the politicians and the
the executives who were forcing people
to get medicated is that just me or does
it seem like people criticize Trump for
not being a Libertarian even though
they're not Libertarians like to think
that Trump wouldn't want the government
to do something would would be really
kind of ridiculous in my opinion because
Donald Trump's not a small government
kind of guy he was never that kind of
dude he he knew how to work the
government in New York to to you know be
able to get at least some buildings
built and stuff so I the idea that
Donald the idea that Donald Trump needs
to be held accountable in the way that
you would hold a Libertarian accountable
seems oh it seems off to me I think
they're more trying to hold him
accountable for trusting people that he
should have known are nefarious Fair
that's the issue I think I can't study
for Trump supporters well who else was
he going to trust it's not like that was
anybody decent to choose from hello
hello hello
yeah yeah he brought on Bolton I think
that was because uh one of his donors
wanted him to bring on John Bolton and
then Bolton stabs in the back yeah Trump
brought on so many dumb people Rex
Tillerson that was the dumbest guy he I
made pouches the most wrong guy look
remember with AIDS in fact he remembered
back then well I I don't remember it but
I've read a lot about it I've been going
I do and my brother's gay you know and I
remember when AIDS was the big thing and
thought you was the problem then too
yeah I just finished watching this uh uh
superb uh mini series from back in the
day called angels in America about the
age of Crisis oh yeah and I I think this
I might even write a book about at some
point because I think people have
forgotten how dark it was and it was a
joke because it was happening to them
and like hahaha and it was it's really
if you look back it was extremely
disturbing how this population was
treated and like I just also plotted I
heard conspiracy theory about the MMR
vaccine 1980 they establish question
they distribute a mass distribution of
the MMR vaccine some new vaccine and it
was this is the conspiracy theories that
it was tainted with HIV right I heard
that a lot of people got it but most
people were able to fight it off it was
the people doing poppers and partying
until 5am that got really sick and then
they were like about gay it's the gay
and it's like no it's because their
bodies are weakened we don't we don't
need that conspiracy because we know
that Bayer had tainted uh hemophilia
medication yeah that's that's
historically yeah fact well have you
heard of Celia Farber she's a great
journalist and she went back in the 90s
when I when I was on my show she brought
me evidence she's a prize-winning
journalist and she she had traced it
back to the salt vaccine the place in
Africa where they tested on those
children the sulk and the save and polio
vaccine is the same place AIDS
originated you know this is a uh it's
like a it's like a dangerous YouTube
subject either way because I I don't I
don't know I I
I'm not inclined to immediately say that
vaccines caused whatever there's so many
conspiracy theories no but I'm just
saying like experimenting on a captive
population is always bad yeah yeah you
know you can't you can't do that but
like so I just watched Bohemian Rhapsody
the movie
Queen such an amazing Band Bohemian
Rhapsody is it the greatest song of all
time yeah perhaps absolutely and uh so
I'm watching we built this city it's the
greatest that's a good song no he was
the greatest singer ever you think so
he's your favorite yeah I just I queen
is so good it you know and especially
after watching that movie I'm listening
to all their songs again after all this
time and I'm like eclectic yes that's a
good thing about them yeah
operatic just so amazing and
groundbreaking this may be a little
crass but I Love Don't Stop Me Now but
every time I I listen to that I'm like
you know one second thought someone
should have stopped that guy oh God Tim
that's a Michael malice joke what I'm
not saying to be mean I'm not saying it
as a joke I literally people should have
been like someone should have at least
moderated him but this is gonna stop him
but yeah that wasn't the time
but but it's it's you're you know
Michael's over here he's very laughing
he likes it but I'm not saying it's a
joke I'm saying it this guy was doing
drugs he was partying non-stop all the
time that destroys his immune system he
contracts HIV and I'm just like
that that's such a brutal thing but you
know my point is when it comes to these
conspiracy theories about what really
happened I'm like these stories are all
people who as like Ian pointed out are
doing a bunch of drugs all the time rock
and roll they're having tons of sex all
the time
we have actually a control group for
this because we have someone here who
had that level of Fame so when you were
like at the top of your power how would
someone have put you in check if they
wanted to because like when you're like
Freddie Mercury level I feel like no one
can tell you anything no you're damn
right yeah if they try you're out of
there right you're not gonna tell me I
made this money this is my money and
I'll do with it as I choose yeah right
now it is yeah we're just we're just
people like they end up dead that is the
truth no but but my point is not that
you could have stopped Freddie Mercury
my point is that no I hear you but I'm
just saying it's interesting we can
actually talk to someone at that level
of faith I I wouldn't let nobody stop no
but right right but my point is not that
he would have been stopped this my point
is where how does this disease come
about because these people can't be
stopped right these celebrities Ultra
rock stars promiscuous they don't want
to stop it's a big suicidal trip it's
like hey you've you've reached the peak
and you've done everything there is to
do you don't want to downslide now
you're not going back you're going out
yeah I want to bring you No One's Gonna
yeah right into the occult I got to
bring up so so it is a dark story to
talk about I mean no disrespect you know
it's it's a terrible story but we did
talk about this great new uh uh there's
a great stride that has been taken as is
underway uh Joe Biden has cured cancer
ladies and gentlemen we have this from
the post-millennial Joe Biden breaking
he claims we ended cancer as we know it
the real story because I'm not here to
bury the lead or manipulate you is that
Biden mumbled what sounded like we ended
cancer as we know it seemingly on
accident and I just find it kind of sad
and humorous but here I'm so glad I
donated money to him oh my god let's
play the clip yeah and fed everything at
all Joe what would you do
I said I'd cure cancer they looked at me
like why cancer because no one thinks we
can
that's why and we can't yeah that's why
I mean and the cancers we know it
the clip it's a little late for Bo huh
here's I I got I gotta I gotta say to
the post millennial post millennial do
not clip audio do not clip the audio
right after a word has spoken while he's
still speaking because that diminishes
the the veracity of making this claim
for all we know he said we ended cancer
as we know what I mean to say is we can
end cancer reason but you cut him off
and now we don't know the content but
I'll give you some more context if you
look this up during the campaign the
2020 campaign he explicitly said when
I'm elected we will cure cancer yes he
did yes yeah he did but he but if you
look at the whole context it was like
we're not going to stop until we put
enough resources to solve this so it was
out of context the sentence that sounds
crazy and I'm sure that's what it's a
throwback for him by the way I had this
tweet and I think you will get out to it
all those bio labs in the Ukraine are
for us to come up with a cure for cancer
and to confirm what you're saying it was
in otumo Iowa June 11 2019 Biden said he
would quote cure cancer the other thing
that I'm really excited about is if
Trump Biden as the two candidates it
will be literally impossible to convince
Joe Biden that he's not living in 2020.
literally that's what I wondered about
what he said here I think what he meant
to say was we're gonna cure cancer as we
know it but he said it in the present
tense yes he's done he's okay so this is
not the worst thing he's done there was
a famous story where he kept saying
Libya instead of Syria and it's it's
kind of a big deal if the president
commander-in-chief is speaking to the
armed forces and this he was he was
speaking at the U.N or whatever but
imagine he goes to a meeting is in a
situation room he's like we got a bomb
Libya and they're like are you sure like
yeah just just get him out of there just
just do it and it's like okay I guess
then it's like breaking news the next
day New York Times U.S declares war on
Libyan we're like why wouldn't we did
that already though
lately France did it for us yeah you
know if he was like instead of saying we
got to send troops and he's talking to
his generals we got to send troops and
he says troops are in the generals will
be like what
you know what's really funny is that
there was a lot of talk like this when
Trump was in office and people on the
left Democrats were freaking out like
they think Trump's an idiot and I can't
believe this guy's Community yeah this
guy's commander-in-chief but I don't
think Republicans have that fear about
Biden because there's really an
understanding that he's not running
anything so he's like saying all these
things everyone's just like yeah who
cares like we know he's not running the
military I don't I don't understand that
like he's he's he it's it's never Joe
Biden actually calling shots yes he's
definitely got handlers that are telling
him what to say he admits it at the
podium constantly that's because they'll
get mad at me they want me to say this
he he tells people all the time and
that's been his career that's why I got
the nomination he was a team player he's
not a party hack I agree and disagree I
think it's true he has AIDS and and
hey good news Jack good news Jack
Joe Biden has White House aides who tell
him his staff members what to say and
who to call upon and things like this
and he says they're going to get mad
people assume that means there's a
there's like a CIA Puppet Master pulling
strings when it could just be that Biden
has staff members who get angry when he
asks them for help they give him help
and then he doesn't do what they say it
doesn't mean that he's literally being
told he has to do things I think it's a
combination of the two I think he does
just go with the flow and is told to do
things but then he also just does things
himself and that creates chaos I also
think that in many ways of similar to
Trump because Trump very clearly seemed
to not be a big picture was a big
picture guy and wasn't worried about the
minutia and it seemed very clear it's
like okay I trust you because when
you're running like a trump
organizational tell organization you're
not looking at the hotel in Atlanta the
hotel New York you have someone you
trust they're there and you delegate it
so you know that's kind of I'm sure that
was a situation during his presidency
and that's why a lot of went off the
rails because he didn't have a strong
deck of people to staff and then they're
just going rogue yeah bragging about it
I don't know I I don't even think this
Biden is the other Biden you don't look
nothing like the original Biden neither
do you well that's true
look who's talking yeah that's true you
got plastic surgery that's the funniest
thing is that what it is yeah you got
hair plugs for sure oh yeah he's got to
live for sure yeah I mean they all bug
GED by much square face yeah well they
they pull your flesh back you know well
I've had that so I know that but still
his cheekbones were much wider and are
you the original Joe Biden is that what
you're trying to tell us I think he's
being portrayed by an actor right I do I
think he's wearing a mask and he's a
mask a plus pass did you guys see The
Jamie Foxx video no Jamie Foxx brought a
video and he's like hey guys you know
I'm all right and then everyone started
showing these like celebrity headshot
pictures of his face alongside his cell
phone video where he's pale
and it's really simple it's it's the
it's the it's the width of the camera
lens so you you there's a you Google
this YouTube video camera lens
Distortion face and you can see a guy's
face changing Shades I gotta ask you
Roseanne
let me ask you this Roseanne if you've
you've you're been Hollywood for decades
if you're gonna have an actor who's
going to play Joe Biden when you have an
actor who knows how to deliver the lines
well they told him to act like he's got
the Alzheimer's why would she say that
what you want an actor who acts like he
doesn't have the outside no because
there it's all a show it's all a show
for the American people well that was a
bit too much now that's a sitcom I would
like that's true yeah that's true
because people have to see how it works
look at it's The Sopranos why is nobody
saying what's going on is it's the Noose
Sopranos with the Biden films I think
you should bring back the Golden Girls
and have them but half of all have
Alzheimer's here's what I think is funny
when it comes to the they show a picture
of Biden next to an older picture of
mine it says by Dan or whatever and
they're like by Dan versus Biden like
like Biden right now is actually by Dan
they call them and it's it's like
they're they point to his ears
right but I'm like okay dude he got a
facelift yeah
right right and so people like one of my
ears is different and they're like why
is his face a different shape different
camera lens man like there's a bunch of
different photos of different people
they do see the one he was scratched in
the back of his head and The Mask
it's his loose old skin now it was way
too much skin I think it's Jim Carrey
planning it could be
no no no no no no it's all righty then
it's a Wonder Years Fred Savage and the
other guy became Marilyn Manson do you
know you ever see that Family Guy
episode where uh Rush Limbaugh was
actually uh Rush Limbaugh was actually
Fred Savage yeah and he's and he's also
Michael Moore and he's like you know
after The Wonder Years acting dried up
but he had this thirst to act so he just
became all of these personalities what
about this conspiracy theory that it was
uh Baron running Trump's Twitter because
no like 80 no no seven-year-old senior
citizen could be that much of a great
poster it's got to be this kid
or that uh Steve Van and his Baron from
the future oh yeah yeah
uh anyway what were we talking about how
someone's acting for Biden uh acting as
Biden because that's why
that's why he speaks like that because
you just can't hit it out of the park so
you've got to pick something that's off
and just go commit to it no come on like
I'm just Joe Biden got a bunch of
surgery he got plastic surgery got his
hair done it's really disturbing Hillary
he's falling apart he's got plates in
his brain he can barely talk it's like
he's just he's just losing what he's
just a placeholder is that what you
think yeah that that was um what
magazine was it Atlantic oh yeah 2020
election they said time wasn't it with
the no no no no Atlantic said stay alive
Joe Biden all you need is your corporeal
form yeah they were outright saying we
just need a guy who can get votes but
for four years it was pretty clear
during the Trump presidency that the
president has far less Powers than we
are told and it was a complaint of his
that it's like the government's running
itself and I'm not they're they're
bragging about how they kind of you know
did enruns about him and the Press was
cheering it on like especially with the
like oh
what do you mean the cheering on the
idea that for the first time in my life
time the president had his authority
rescinded and revoked now there's
there's bad things to that in terms of
what Trump want to do like ending War
but the idea the present all of a sudden
was being curtailed I was like Wow as a
first no but I meant because that's a
disruption of our whole uh
constitutional republic what were they
like we're trying to destroy the
executive branch and bring up you know
was it destroying it or was it just
demonstrating how it really works no
they tried to disrupt the whole balance
of power in our government
they said they said before uh Trump even
was inaugurated they were going to
impeach him yeah now now we have um I
did this I covered this this morning uh
Kevin McCarthy announces a strongly
worded letter to be sent after Rand Paul
said a strongly worded letter a second
without fauchy oh two times the second
one oh if it's a third one three strikes
and nothing happens yeah I told her I
treated I tweeted Iran Paul that he
should ask fauci for a cure for his
impotence because it's insane how these
Republicans uh Chuck Grassley is another
one Chuck Grassley was either ranking a
member of the House of the Senate excuse
me District committee he wrote letters
to the uh doj this is the Trump doj
about Julie swetnik I'm Like This
Woman's lying brazily in front of
Congress he doesn't get a call returned
writes another letter year later doesn't
get a call return sends out a press
release so the Republicans are bragging
that they can't even get a call return
this is something to be cringing and
embarrassing about instead of telling
your voters it's disgusting so McCarthy
announces a potential that this this may
lead to an impeachment inquiry oh wow
not even an impeachment an inquiry and
to a maybe eventually later click on
this link and send me money that's how
it works it's just this total con job
yep
all of them are in on it all of them
well let's uh let's let's there's
there's times there are change in
because we have an election coming up
let's jump to this story from NBC News
uh okay Ron DeSantis fire staffer Who
retweeted video with Nazi imagery oh God
so um they say Nate Hockman a
Communications staffer over the weekend
promoted and then deleted a video that
superimposed a son and rad over the
candidate's face I believe that's called
the black Sun yeah yeah yeah uh so this
video is super cringe ice it's got Kate
Bush playing in the background it's one
of those meme videos
so it's this video it's like Trump he's
got an irritating voice hey look who's
talking I know that was a joke that how
come no one left has nothing against me
hey someone put a laugh track for
Roseanne so she feels more at home
a live studio audience
do you anymore
and I saw she's really sweet
yeah that's right I ruined your secret
but that's disturbing
well so when I first heard this someone
like a a pro-trump kind of person was
like a descended stamp a campaign
staffer just retweeted this I saw Phil
you retweeted it you were like this
looks like intentional sabotage yeah or
something it looked like it looked like
something that someone would do if they
were looking to harm the Rhonda Santos
campaign no that's why I don't believe
it I'm like certainly this is a trump
supporter trying to make it look like
DeSantis did something wrong but firing
the guy was the right move yes
or I think that the Santa's role in this
movie is he's playing the heel for Trump
that's what I think do you think I think
it's all a movie and it's all to you
know get people to actually have some
awareness of what's right in front of
their damn face and uh wake up to it and
yeah I think he's playing the heel
because the you know people that don't
want to vote Democrat no more they're
going either independent or they're
actually thinking I'll go a little bit
further and maybe I'll vote DeSantis but
then they're like whoa he's even more
far right than Trump so then they're
going to look at Trump should I play the
video some people can see what we're
talking about yeah I want to point out
too people said that uh whoever made it
had had something against me because the
guy's wearing a beanie with the gray
Brim
I'm not going to play the audio because
it's just Kate Bush and I don't want to
get it coming up that hill
I think it is you're Republicans your
favorite President it's basically he's
he's like sad and smoking and he's
wearing a beanie and he's got and
Trump's waving an LGBT flag I'll just
jump through it I need to watch the
whole thing then it like shows to santis
oh you know what I gotta show the super
cringe part when he appears in the door
like what what is this
and then he's like wearing a oh now the
wojak is happy and he's like oh look
it's Rhonda Santa's spaceships and women
in bikinis this is good this is so many
levels of irony it's hard to figure out
if it's Earnest or not that's why I'm
like I don't believe they actually made
this because it's so cringe but it's the
end where the Nazis are Marching towards
the Sun and rad with the Santas in the
Middle where I was like okay there's no
way this is from his campaign if you
know what is if you know what the the
imagery is it's a very jarring to be
like oh oh that's where you're going I
gotta bounce myself I started laughing
yeah I did too he's hilarious I was like
what is this the whole thing is is
ridiculous here we go look bad story oh
wow
the way you described it I thought like
oh it's in the background the guy didn't
notice it it's only no
it's like jarring it's spinning around
god well the game now do you the games
do not like DeSantis OverWatch
holy crap so they're doing this
but this was retweeted by his campaign
staff so when I'm actually on the staff
not just the supporter no it was just
look look this is the story
who treated video with Nazi imagery
sorry even if that Nazi imagery wasn't
there you do not retweet this video
because it makes the scientist look like
a tool oh this is this is the Santa's
campaign I I don't I don't understand
how someone had this tweeted you
probably know who I referred to I forgot
the guy's name and he goes like uh 2020
the Santa's greatest government America
2021 2022 2023 like Santa's is terrible
like it flipped on a dime well because
he got he got remember
what DeSantis took measurements against
I mean he took measures against the
lgbtq plus community in Florida and
Disney and they didn't like that and
then remember just like two weeks ago
Trump had the big
pro-lgbtq party at Mar-A-Lago DeSantis
is attacking from the front I'm
surprised what I meant is I'm surprised
that how many how the Republicans all
flipped overnight to hating DeSantis it
was so weird and I'm not I'm not
surprised for two reasons the first uh
attack against the sentence was
disloyalty that Trump which makes sense
decides he's gonna go to a bunch of big
neocon donors established Republican
donors to run against Trump it's like
you know kick him and kicking Trump in
the butt yeah uh but then and he did it
because
he wanted to go even more right getting
rid of gay uh stuff which some you know
what a lot of parents think was the
right thing to do but then you know he
brings in Sorrows as a backer so it's
like I don't wow that's not he didn't
bring a source as a Becca he takes Soros
money I don't think no that's the
complete that's that's complete I read
that in two or three sources you just
said 20 minutes ago you don't believe
all that stuff I read it in two or three
yeah it's not true it's complete like
okay so that might not be true and they
and they lied claiming that Soros
endorsed to sandus which is not true
either they've been they've been trying
to look they I don't trust anything that
uh you know I I want to say this
correctly but anything that has to do
with Children's School books yes and
being pro
um child pornography in the schools I
I'm not for that okay and I'm not for
anything that George Soros is for yes
amen and we're both saying this is
Jewish people by the way I'll tell you
what this may be
here's what I thought when when the
DeSantis supporters started zealously
insulting me not did they really oh it's
it's it's Relentless but it's not like
I'm you know I'm not I I don't I get
attacked by everybody on Twitter right
but they act very much like antifa style
left us on Twitter tweet in the very
same way and so at first I thought these
people are trying to sink DeSantis by by
false wagging him pretend to be a Santa
supporter like you see a lot of these
accounts that pretend to be Democrats
and say stupid things people fall for it
and then it was to set as his own
campaign staff that started insulting me
did they really like you uh
the communications people right okay I
know them okay uh yeah they're they're
miserable at their jobs and so without
naming I'll I don't wanna I don't want
to get people dragged and then get them
yeah or whatever but there's a handful
of high profile conservative pundits who
were pro-desantis all last year and now
will are outspoken against them because
these these uh staffers supporters and
surrogates on Twitter are the most vile
people not all of them not every single
one of course there are a lot of good
people I have friends who are big very
fine people very fine people well some
and some I think are very fine people
but even when I've defended DeSantis I
get attacked for it
and then I get these same people who
have insulted me demanding that I cover
their stories in defense of descendants
tweeting at me and I'm just like you
people are despicable
so I'm just like I'm not having it you
know you know that video that uh LGBT
video that was uh retweeted by uh the
status war room that was made by the
DeSantis campaign they passed it off to
a third party to make it seem like they
didn't make it but they did I I'm I'm
not sure I think it's Colin tell Pro the
whole thing something that is his
campaign yeah wow I think he's playing
the heavy the heel something is not
adding up because the biggest criticism
of trump from even from Trump supporters
is he didn't deliver the goods and in
his defense you know he had he lost the
house you know he had he only had like
50 Senators to begin with and whatever
and the argument is well DeSantis did in
Florida the fact that he's like
overnight become like a joke and like
Jeb Bush like I've never seen any
politicians fortunes flip so quickly in
my lifetime
but Howard got her what had a raw deal
right I know because Disney but he could
point to something specific and I can
point to something specific with Rhonda
santis what I'm leading the Great
American combat that was his campaign
announcement that moment was like a bang
and all of a sudden people were like wow
I think you're right though Roseanne or
at least you're saying something
interesting in that he went hard against
Disney which is like one of the most
powerful corporations and then Disney
never really said anything about it
publicly yeah oh yes they do what's her
name Sonny hoyson on the
she says she drives down the street and
Florida screaming
gay gay out the window oh yeah they came
hard well maybe she's a homophobe
Disney came hard for him yes and he
capitulated he didn't stand up against
Disney at the very end he totally
capitulated at some point they said
Disney made a statement like we don't
want we don't kind of want to bury the
hatchet we don't want to push this any
harder the Hatchet by again they bear
the hatchet in him interesting in his
campaign yeah we're in the age of
psychological operations right now so to
think this just to pretend like it's
another year another election year it's
like no no dude we have deep fix Ai and
like massive manipulation in the back
and some people could be twisting this
guy's campaign in in Brazil I think it
was Brazil there was uh some leaked
audio uh and they claimed this
politician I'm not sure if it was
results claim his politician said these
offensive things and it turns out that
one of them was AI generated one of them
was not right and this is exactly what
I've been warning about and this is
exactly why I said when DeSantis
campaign created deep fake images of
trump and fauci to smear Trump and then
labeled it real life Trump I'm like they
just crossed a very very dark line and
descendants
they still have to tweet up as far as I
know they they never said anything about
it they never fired anybody they did
nothing he was fine with it
I think to Santas in terms of leadership
in Florida did a fantastic job it's
great I think I think that's the thing
right because like ever it seems like if
you took off his name and you ask all
these people who hate DeSantis would you
support a governor with this record for
president they trip over themselves
there's a disconnect here for me until
you see his leadership sure sure until
you see the the mistakes made by the
campaign the the uh his failures to
address them and you've got all the you
get all these people who support him
saying that policy matters more than
Charisma et cetera et cetera and I'm
like dude let me just say I think he is
the best politician in the country in
terms of what a polishing can be in
Florida did a great job ask yourself
after all these great things why is
polls are sinking well people in Florida
feel like you just walked out on him to
go campaigning they said he hadn't to
half of the stuff he was in the middle
of and he capitulates at the end so you
know a lot of people in Florida are mad
because he kind of just goes hey I did a
great job here for two years see ya but
you know that's just the nature of
politics in the United States so you get
a chance to race you have to get a
billion dollars to lose an election
I'm going to make two points about that
here's the other thing that's really
crazy if you have any criticism of Joe
Biden and social media right away You're
a trump supporter right yeah if you have
any criticism of trump oh you're you're
DeSantis supporter if you have any
criticism DeSantis your Maga it's
bizarre how binary it's got and I'm just
gonna make two points one is the
argument for DeSantis running now was
Obama in 08 where Obama was supposed to
wait his turn you're supposed to be
Hillary's nomination Obama said screw
that he got that he became the White
House so there's a path there for
DeSantis historically the other is until
Trump the nominee for the Republican
party was always for 40 years the guy
who lost the last time uh Reagan lost in
76 against Gerald Ford he was the
nominee in 80. uh George W bush uh ran
against Reagan in 80 became the nominee
in 88. Bob Dole ran in 92 so the pattern
it's Mitt Romney lost against McCain
then he became nominee 2012. Trump broke
that pattern so there's also room for
running and losing this is the
Republican party it works and then being
the nominee the next time I don't
believe there is a traditional path to
the presidency for Ron DeSantis or Vivek
ramaswamy or Tim Scott but I say Vivek
because he's in third place and most of
the polls even rivaling DeSantis there's
no traditional path the path for these
gentlemen presumably DeSantis in second
place maybe Vivek keeps rising in the
polls is going to be Trump's indictment
and yeah or forced or forced to step
down yes
yeah I don't think that I don't think
that that's going to happen because I I
don't think they can um
they can indict him for a hundred years
and that isn't going to stop can I say
one thing though because and they can't
like keep them off the ballot here's
where you're wrong something really yeah
something really bad is happening now
with Biden appointing but they say
Biden's going to come out and say oh the
CIA is going to be in charge of 2024
election here's something I learned
about when I was writing the book the
white pill about the Soviet Union you
can you know sit there and you could be
like there's nothing you could do to me
I'm gonna be the nominee I'm gonna run
I'm gonna run there's nothing I don't
care you throw the charges you want what
these totalitarian regimes do and I'm
not saying we're in a total regime but
I'm just saying what evil people do they
go that's cool you've got a wife right
and you've got kids right and you've got
grandkids right okay cool we're not
gonna do anything to you so very quickly
when you start targeting those people
everyone starts to fold and with good
reason so they have a lot of those cards
to play and I wouldn't put it past them
there was especially with the the Trump
organization indictments I'll keep this
vague that's true because of that but
there was an individual who was running
who dropped out uh recently and this had
been discussed publicly but I'm not
going to say the individual's name
because they're family but they dropped
out because of the risk of their family
yeah and this was like a trump Maga
candidate and so we'll just leave it at
that but this is a reality yes
well oh it's just so scary and horrible
I I just I'm so afraid I just have to
say I'm so afraid what what are you
afraid of what's happening to our
country and how divided we are how we
can't get how we can't get together to
make it better for all of us we just
yeah but we'll go down fighting at each
other but when the government owners are
getting richer and uh it's just but but
Roseanne look at her way when the
government gets together it screws over
the middle class for in the favor of
people of political access and power
well that's what I'm saying I'm scared
of that now how bad it's going to get
regular people do you think we should
abolish the 17th Amendment which one is
that uh popular vote for senators by I
think that's a great idea because then
that's a great idea but the whole know
about it the Senate used to be appointed
by each state like the house the
legislature of each state would pick the
Senators I thought it was still that way
no no you vote for your senator in
whatever state you live in right no but
it used to be like the the people don't
vote the state congress picks the
Senators for the federal government so
Texas legislature will pick the two
senators and you know why they oh my God
I didn't know how stupid am I that was
just but you know what people were
picking no they are now but after this
amendment this is like in the 1890s 19
times
so so you know the reason for it was I
didn't know the reason for it was
because they said that political
insiders were choosing their friends to
become senators and so they said this is
corruption how do we stop it have the
people directly vote for their Senator
which I think was a bad idea the big
cost is the whole point was that the
Senate and the house were supposed to be
as different as possible the Senate were
like the like representing the states
and also called this aristocracy like
big shots who are going to Washington
they're kind of like Elites and they're
there to represent the state
specifically and they're not going to be
privy to like the popular whims of the
day so where's the house yeah is like
the low life the Lords and Commons it
was kind of sort of like the the house
are like the low life so I don't mean
that in negative way just like the
rabble and it's like this is where we
make our voices heard but so so what
would happen is this you and your local
District state district vote for a
senator representative you're more
likely to know them because they're only
representing a couple thousand to ten
thousand people that individual then
votes for a senator so you now have to
be involved in local politics 70
Amendment got rid of that and now nobody
even knows who their local reps are yeah
they don't know who their Mayors are
half the time probably more than that
but that's also a good thing in this
sense because a lot of times these local
governments and like you see even like
the New York City city council they're a
lot less partisan and ideological
because they're more like cutting deals
and like doing maybe New York is a bad
example recently but a lot of it's just
cutting deals and trying to figure out
what's going to work for everybody and
you're less driven by the uh party uh
Elites well it's just like the guy that
owns the biggest used car lot it has the
biggest say in Congress yeah which is so
corrupt and so horrible I mean I think
we should really take a look at our
government I I like Trump for that
reason because I thought he could
streamline things and make them more
fair and more workable not just him but
sure a whole a whole bunch of people who
had the human being's best interest in
mind who do you think for 2024 Michael
what do I think in what capacity the
president
what do you think what do you think like
who would you prefer
if you had to make a choice be president
based on who's available to to choose I
know the chat room is gonna have a
meltdown I know I know what I would love
to see happen don't say Robert F Kennedy
no I'm not going to say that he's a
sociopath I think he's I I'm not joking
really I think Robert of Kenny Jr is an
absolute Association
what's that you should interview him
sure I'm happy to interview him maybe
I'm sure he's perfectly Charming but the
Kennedy's family are very evil they gave
Rosemary Kennedy lobotomy and they sent
her away pretended she was just on
vacation for decades this is why they
started the Special Olympics look them
up they're they're really Sinister
people Joe Kennedy's they're a drug
dealing family this is talk about Banana
Republic this is how like things happen
in South America you have this big drug
dealer like Pablo Escobar and they they
take over the government that was kind
of a notoriously stolen president yes
yes 1960. my point is what I would love
to see happen is to have a corpse Biden
and a massive Republican reaction in the
Congress and I think that is not in and
that's the only way we in our life hold
on hold on let me finish I told you the
chat was gonna freak out that's the only
time in our lifetime where we had a
balanced budget was when you had a very
weakened Democratic president and a very
Insurgent Republican Congress what year
was that uh 97 98 balance budget we're
so past a damn balance
I did 94 and then they did it but China
we got China in Cuba and Russia coming
for us now I'm more worried about
talking about a balanced budget we're
going to have a we're going to have
another Missile Crisis right at our
doorstep within six months what does one
have to do with the other we're good
they're gonna bomb us to the next World
so we should spend more money yeah
I'm more concerned about the doj
I I think if there is a big house
majority then mayor Garland's gonna get
impeached I don't think so well okay
that's my prediction so what was the
retailer green is already started
talking about it the you've got a decent
handful of insurgent Republicans right
now that are pushing really hard and
even then not pushing as hard as many
people want and then if we get if if you
get a republican majority it's still
going to be dominated by neocons it's
not necessarily that if it's a huge
reaction here's one here's my other
concern and I think I would agree if you
have Trump in again which there's
definitely pluses to that I think on the
state level people like Whitmer Newsom
Kathy hokel are going to be pushing
policies that are so deranged and
radical as a reaction to Trump that
we're it's going to make 2023 look like
a cakewalk well what about that's a big
fear meaning what they pushed in 2023 is
going to look like nothing compared to
what they've told which one do you mean
or no like like now the kind of
they're pushing now oh would you feel
better if it was Michelle Obama's
president and then a republican result I
want a corpse but we the only problem I
have is like what Roseanne was saying
about Cuba like like military you know
International military command and
Michelle Obama is in any way qualified
to deal with some type of military uh
issue in in Cuba did that she did that
diet thing about it wait she's got a and
I'm not saying she's the greatest I'm
not saying she's the greatest military
manner
because she I don't think she's the best
or even like a great military commander
I have nothing to go on but way better
than someone's falling into dementia
that doesn't no it doesn't matter in
this context it doesn't it doesn't
matter just said that he cured cancer I
I know what you're saying but the point
the point that I'm making is if it
whether it be Michelle Obama who's
ignorant about military
uh whatever military action or Joe Biden
who's who's not in contact with reality
it doesn't matter because the people
making the decisions are still going to
be the general that's exactly that's not
good listen no no one's thinking it's
good it's not up it's not up for debate
Barack would kind of run the shot
yes this is his third term listen
there's nobody but Trump nobody but
Trump can do what needs to be done and
you know what they're already you know
you're gonna say everything I say is a
tin foil hat but and my son does too I
know but people that's quite an intro
but but I think things are going to
change real big by the end of the year I
do I just I agree with you I don't think
that the Republicans are going to
impeach nobody they're all in bed and
they all took Epstein wait hold on
they're not going to do that I'm saying
if there is a huge reaction against but
because when Biden was elected in 2020
or voted in whatever calm down chat room
they for the first time like ever The
House of the other party picked up seats
so what I'm saying is if Biden squeaks
through in 2024 it would not be
impossible for the house to massively
have that red wave that was supposed to
happen in 2022. and then there might be
enough to actually start really doing
impeachments
I don't think we're going to have no
electricity 24. I'll bet how much 100
bucks how much you got not as much as
you
I'll bet big I don't think we're going
to have a thousand dollars all right
shake hands I hate shaking hand go like
this it's worth it oh that was good a
thousand dollars so if we have an
election 2024 you're gonna give me a
thousand dollars uh-huh okay Jake does
she have it yeah yeah does she have you
don't have like a Britney Spears
relationship with her right she has she
has control of her money not a thousand
bucks but okay you're gonna have to pay
me a thousand one we do not have money I
would be delighted and I'll buy you a
nice dinner on top of that why do you
think there won't be an election because
I think the corruption is just beginning
to uh come out and I think it's going to
Avalanche the corruption of the Biden
Administration and the money they took
versus going to be about Ukraine and
Russia then it's going to go into China
then it's going to go into the doj and
it's going to be like a big old no
prompt an election huh that would prompt
an election no because I think that it's
going to get so bad in the streets too
that I think the military is going to
step in I mean Michael we've talked
about the uh many people have come on
the show said this is like the one time
they actually are not convinced there
will be an election that is not to say
we hear that every four years but no no
no no no come on yes not like now I
remember very vividly at newsmax.com in
2000 they were arguing that Clinton is
not going to leave the White House and
they argued that in 2016. yes but that's
not every single time this is the Trump
the culture War period do you want
anything too I'll bet a thousand dollars
with you too I didn't say there wasn't
going to be election I'm saying we've
had people on the show where we've
discussed what is the potentiality what
is the percentage rate of there not
being an election and it's not zero we
had that's it's not zero that's fair we
had an election during the Civil War we
had an election during World War II so
I'm my the best predictor of future
behavior is history so if there was
precedent for cancer elections I'd be
more receptive to this argument I don't
and here's the thing they don't need to
cancel it exactly that's the point it's
much better for them to have a
perception that we this is we have a
when Trudeau got reelected hold on let
me finish my points in one second when
Trudeau just got reelected with the
exact same number of seats as previously
he said oh I have a mandate so they will
absolutely have the election whatever
happens they'll say we have a man they
do with whatever we need to clarify this
information comes
uh things that certain people don't
think are ever going to be proven okay
we need to clarify this bet
what do you mean by election
uh
I I mean
um
a a presidential election yeah people go
in and vote okay so in 1876 people went
in to vote Yes and then the president
was determined by a committee no there
are two sets of electors in Florida I
just read a book about this and they and
they had elections and the election
didn't matter it did matter it just it
was question of which the votes are the
ones to count and you know why who
decided which votes to count because
yeah they had a they had a conference
and so and they still had the election
they decided we are going to end
reconstruction and we're we're going to
split this up so that so that we don't
have another that's a historical myth
I'm telling you I just read a book about
this literally like in the last six
months like so that was why is that book
correct than what I read not correct
because okay I don't know maybe I'm
wrong the point is I just read a book
about this this has been a historical
thing that they cut this deal behind the
scenes it was much more complicated than
that uh that's all I'm gonna say but I'm
not here to argue about 1876. well with
modern day elections I'm concerned that
there's gonna be a dog and pony show and
they're like hey everybody voted and
they're like hey but we're just gonna go
in the back room and count it and tell
you what the answer is you're like dude
show me the votes in public like there's
no for them to actually have military
law it's really hard to put that over
but it might already be under a military
law and a lot of people don't know that
we are have you seen what your your
average SWAT team looks like they look
just like Special Forces
let me just read this for you sure and
then you know I'm not saying you have to
believe it but this is just Wikipedia
and it's not like it's an absolute
Source sure it says the result of the
election remain among the most disputed
ever although it's not disputed that
Tilden outpoled Hayes in the popular
vote they were wide allegations of
election electoral fraud election
violence and other disenfranchisement of
predominantly Republican black voters
right after our first count of votes
till then had won by 184 to hazes 165
with 20 votes from four states
unresolved Florida Louisiana South
Carolina both parties reported their
candidate to have won the state right
Oregon one elector et cetera et cetera
and informal back room deal was struck
to resolve the votes the compromise of
1877. in the deal the Democrats conceded
the 20 contested electoral votes to
Hayes resulting in a 185 to 184 victory
in return the Republicans agreed to
withdraw federal troops in the South
marking the end of reconstruction right
but there's a difference between uh
withdrawing troops and ending
reconstruction
well sure whatever whatever it is the
point is the point is the idea of the
election did not matter because you can
argue that the election mattered in the
sense that the votes were there but if
if It ultimately comes down to a group
of man meeting and saying which votes
should we count
right my point is not that the votes are
completely out of the question and have
nothing to do with what's going on it's
that the decision ultimately comes down
to a group of better men that's that's
the electoral college right like there
was arguments in 2016 that even the
people who Trump had won those States
they should still vote for Hillary like
there was a lot of corporate journals
all right Hamilton electors yeah my
point is in Georgia are we going to have
an election where even you know where
where you the votes come through there
are some legal battles But ultimately
they count and we're like that that's it
or is it going to be a dispute where
everyone's fighting and arguing in the
streets I think that's what it is
I lean towards uh your line of thinking
so there will be an election is what I'm
saying the votes will be counted and
then just like 2020 there is going to be
widespread dispute here's why I don't
think there's gonna be people in the
streets because there weren't people in
the streets during covet
a lot of these the lockdowns and the and
the pushback was far less than if you
had set us all down I think everyone in
this room and it was 2019 and you said
all right if these state governments are
going to make it that you're not allowed
to leave your house for two weeks for
basically for a lot what a lot of people
think is no reason are the American
people gonna stand for this or is it
going to be violence we would have all
said they're never going to be able to
get away with it but they did so I I
disagree okay let me hear you so why did
people Riot like crazy all over the
country we we joke we call it the 529
Insurrection now on the surface the
media says black lives matter but as
we've discussed in great detail the real
reason people in New York were rampaging
through the streets was because they
were locked inside and they had gone
insane and then their anger was directed
towards some random cause so you had the
famous story where a guy calls 9-1-1
after people were ransacking his
building ransacking his apartment
building had nothing to do with BLM he
called the police said they're breaking
into my building what do I do and they
said sir the city is under attack what
would you have us do
on the surface everybody said it was BLM
but the real anger that was within
people was because they had been
isolated they were getting pain sickly
from lack of vitamin D malnourishment
and then a catalyst sparked it off and
they went nuts Tim I don't think there
was as much anti-covet pushback in the
anti-covet populations and areas as I
would have expected in 2019. I agree
that's all I'm saying I agree with the
idea that Republicans and conservatives
who were complaining didn't do anything
else that's all I'm saying but I believe
the real reason for the mass unrest was
not George Floyd that was just a spark
to give an excuse to people who are go
losing their mind think about it though
they bust in people and paid um left
piles and pallets of bricks and stuff
they brought in their operatives and
took it well we don't know that's him it
is true because it was all over the news
they'd find it they'd find it people
were posting old photos of construction
sites and claiming that they were just
placed there but that's just internet
conjecture Tim you had a lot but I I saw
I saw a lot of
uh uh stuff on the internet that
would
like January 6th suggests to me that
there were
operatives who took advantage and were
being busting and paid to like aggravate
bad situations so you think the rights
were not people pushing against covet I
think there were people yeah I think I
think there was that and I think there
were uh aggravators added to it what
about Ferguson no one was locked in
their homes during Ferguson and there
was riots for a long time Baltimore is
another one so Ferguson was was not this
like so in the the 529 George Floyd area
some of the worst rights we've seen in
decades that happened all over the
country right and even at the same time
and even in small cities that people
never covered Michael Tracy famously
went down to these cities that was unpre
like what when Michael Brown was killed
we didn't see writing to that degree
outside of Ferguson it was just Ferguson
which is exactly my point it could come
from the Grassroots it did not it came
from the Grassroots these people Michael
Brown was all in the media too because
no no it didn't come from the Grassroots
it came from agitators and they were
paid I don't I don't know my point is
people who turned onto TVs who have been
angry for a very long time who've been
taught that things are shitty for them
that they should be angry so and so
forth saw that they could go out and
manifest their anger and not only have
no consequences but will be lauded for
it I agree so that's going to encourage
a lot of people who don't have to lose
their money
and what I'm saying is the anger was not
because of black lives matter a small
component their anger was because people
were locked in their apartments and
couldn't leave they were becoming
dejected angry and vicious and then they
said hey you're angry at this and they
were like I can go outside and be angry
now and they let it all out being part
of it too yeah I can see that being a
part of it but I think that they I think
that the owners of this country saw an
opportunity to uh burn down small
businesses yes burn down small
businesses and hurt neighborhoods that
they had already targeted anyway with
big corporate fascism you know what it
is I I I've said this before and I want
to say it to get your guys's reaction
far left extremists tore down the
barricades of the White House injuring
70 plus police officers set fire to a
guard post right set fire to St John's
Church Force the president into a bunker
if Donald Trump ordered the police to
stand down he would be president today
ordered the police to stand out
on 5 29 2020 if Donald Trump ordered the
police if Bill Barr whoever ordered the
police in D.C to stand down and let the
far left do whatever they want we would
not be talking about January 6. yeah but
would be talking about the torching of
the White House but can is I think we
would have had the White House torched
there's also some downsides I guess well
so so my point is this and Donald Trump
did does not understand politics
strategy uh culture cultural War
conflict Etc January 6. the police are
taking selfies with people it becomes
the Insurrection if these extremists
burn down St John's Church if they tore
the fences down if they actually
breached the White House
Trump would come out and say we had fear
that innocent people would be harmed if
we if we Advanced and engaged in active
conflict in the streets of DC we just
had the smartest thing to do would be to
save personnel and back off I'm sorry
America far left extremists have
destroyed elements of DC in our
government and that would have Justified
Insurrection act or other actions it
bothers me about January 6th Man
understand what you're saying yeah like
letting people destroy your home just to
get political to play the victim and be
like Oh nobody live in the capital if
right right so the issue is this Donald
Trump stopped
wait a minute okay let me ask this why
do you think they put up all those uh
barricades and uh barbed wire fences
around D.C all right are you talking
about Ford January 6th or afterwards
after afterwards was as a show of force
to basically to intimidate the the
American people Tim I would agree with
you why was everything facing in and not
out
uh why were the fence is facing in
towards the capital I don't think that's
true yeah we like we we're but yeah but
like we we have people who come from DC
all the time that that was not something
anyone ever said and we never saw it the
thing about 529 I would agree with you
more if the media weren't especially at
that time so invested in scripting a
narrative that was only tangentially
related to reality and I think you
remembered everyone hold on let me
finish my point remember it's very
vividly that we were told that Kobe is a
problem you have to stay in your house
and then as soon as these rides hit off
you have to be in the streets protesting
and you're going to be immune from covid
and there's a limit there is a limit
that regular Americans can withstand uh
what I don't think Trump standing down
would have hit that limit I'm sorry I
can't say around the White House and
burn down St John's Church St John's
Church was on fire yeah and they stopped
it if they didn't it would have burned
to the ground and they would have and
then people but then they would have won
and this no no they they they did win so
the issue is this
do you think like the CIA I'll put it
this way I was talking to Occupy Wall
Street activists back 12 years ago
and I said do you think that it's fuel
Japan the Ninja Warrior walks up to the
front Gates and knocks on the emperor's
door and say we hereby demand the
emperor stand down yeah he says I'm the
one who knocks or does the ninja dress
like a a servant sneak in the middle of
the night put a drop a few points into
the emperor and then sneak out the the
the in Warfare it's it's it's it's
surreptitious it's Espionage it's
manipulation it's psychological conflict
and warfare my point is this nobody
should be violent January 6th should
have never happened five to nine should
not have happened my point is whether
you care it has nothing to do with what
should or shouldn't happen it has to do
with the logical steps of what does
happen on January 6 people stormed into
the capital the media then showed all
these images and said Insurrection
violence breaking out people fighting
and that terrifies people who don't pay
attention sure if on 529 they did the
same thing and had the police taking
selfies with protesters and letting them
ransack the media can try and that is an
advantage that the establishment has but
there is a a limit St John's Church
being burnt to the ground guard post
being burned the president being locked
in his bunker for for two days they
burned down police stations and no one
cared because they weren't disgusting
that's not true that no one cared black
lives matter went from its highest
approval rating ever to its lowest point
ever following those no one cared to the
point that it would have made a
difference in having Trump reelected I
think with I think you're wrong May 29
it all takes is like an ABC article that
says Trump let them burn the White House
Down and that would have just wrecked
his chances yes there you go yeah I
disagree some people everything bad is
Trump's fault no some people say this
where you're really going to think I'm
crazy but some people say that Trump
signed the thing on December 18th called
continuation I'm sorry some people say a
lot of them military people and believe
I actually stick my nose in military
business that Trump signed a thing on
December 18th continuation of government
and that we are under limited uh martial
law right now already none of that
stuff's true well how do you know
I'll start from the beginning first we
can talk about the actors
I believe that they were all arrested oh
no I believe that they too oh no here we
go here we go they're playing their
parts and that we're going to see
military tribunals
I believe it what about another thousand
so the military tribunals will be public
they already have happened will they be
public by the end of the year yes I know
a thousand dollars Rosanna I liked and
bucks on that too okay so a thousand
dollars that there will be no public
military tribunals no I'm saying there
will be and I'm saying there's not the
BET um limited Military tribunals will
be shown by the end of this year and I'm
saying no so will you bet a thousand
dollars no it's only like four months
thousand bucks on that okay here we go I
love four months I love Roseanne's
optimism
I guess when you have Roseanne money you
can just make these things
it's not because we have the video clips
here I can show you close this is why I
brought her so I could be rich
and all kinds of stuff that you've never
seen I can show you stuff but I'll tell
you why I believe it because I read The
Art of War and I know that Trump's a
badass and he's not going to let any of
them get away with anything and he
locked up Cheyenne Mountain and they
can't get at it too bad how do you know
that because it's it's all in the
if I document s Cheyenne Mountain is
locked up you say hey
Tim Tim pool no so let me let me tell
you my favorite my favorite thing ever
is uh we are watching a flat Earth video
last week
and it's an oval and and my favorite
Spirit actually my favorite thing is
okay every single Die Hard flat earther
says why can't we travel to Antarctica
it's strange exactly what are you
talking about I know I know he went
there
Joel that's what that thing was going
for the uh Titanic deal it was trying to
get to Antarctica the Pentagon react
Cheyenne Mountain in 2020.
when did Trump lock it up this is where
they have to start turn the screen for
her so she can see this is where they
have the Stargate what's in it oh that's
what it starts got the headlines she
could see yeah this is 2020. Joshua's in
it when did Trump lock it down
uh in 21. Trump wasn't president 21.
yeah he was the first week oh right
right right sorry sorry you are
absolutely right on January 20th well
the first month whatever was
Cheyenne Mountain you can't trust Google
they're controlled opposition this is
like underground research facility
Cheyenne Mountain look it's called the
dumb deep underground military base
the Dom I'm making so much money
[Laughter]
I was just in Colorado Springs they were
probably in those mountains that's where
NORAD command is we drove by there look
under dumb
why is it
um
look under dumb no first do Cheyenne
Mountain I I did search for it there's
nothing there nothing comes up and okay
you can make the argument Google's
hiding it but yeah they are okay so when
when people come out and say one Putin
gave remember when Putin gave Trump the
soccer ball when was that no
[Laughter]
Putin gave Trump the soccer ball oh
there we go yeah 2018. aha
well it's five years ago she still got
you shouldn't have better that never
happened no this is it didn't happen
okay
that's what I'm talking about diplomacy
that's over there in Cheyenne Mountain
check that out I've got an article from
Daily Mail says why is the US military
moving back into Stargate base deep
under the Rocky Mountains a decade after
it was abandoned but this is from 2015.
right yeah that's when it started 2015.
there are a lot of things we don't know
about there's a lot of things the
government is doing there's nothing I
don't know about honey I am a nosy
woman and I can get in anywhere yeah
one thing is when I'm you're as famous
and damn good looking is me Tim
all right then stick my nose in
anybody's business I know how I'm a
grandmother and I have stuck my nose in
the thick of it this time was Michael
Jackson guilty what they accused him of
I'm talking about uh Cheyenne mountains
we're talking about that yeah
I know a lot of military people and I I
do think that the
America they're in for a big old wake-up
call back to Michael Jackson four months
dude they're gonna get way worse before
they get better but you better wake up
because wake up wake up and snap out of
it people you've got a lot of work to do
I can imagine deep fake technology
Unleashed on the humans like um there's
stuff called talking plasma that the
military is working on triangulate
lasers and then create a ball of plasma
they'll move it around on a radar looks
like a UFO and they can project sound
through the thing I got one sentence
Roseanne they can clone but hold on one
sentence will you please please please
have Ian on your podcast I'd love to
that's a uh two hours of them can I
let's get 15 minutes we have the story
from the Daily Mail okay Former Defense
officials says the U.S has recovered
technology that quote did not originate
on this Earth discuss I don't buy it
they're always going to tell us it's
alien it's always a distraction you know
what the real story is what former
Defense official says he was told by
someone in government they've discovered
technology offer technology so the Daily
Mail is framing it in such a way that it
makes it sound like he's definitively
saying he was party to it but he's
actually if you read it he's actually
saying uh America may have in our
possession and that uh he believes it
happened because uh what's the exact
quote
um he says melon says he expects new
information will surface blah blah
I've been told that we have recovered
technology that did not originate on
this Earth by officials in the dod and
my former intelligence officials that
means it originated in
Antarctica's under it there was there's
a Stargate Antarctica I'm going to make
one point my grandfather was a big shot
air traffic controller in the Soviet
Union high up in the in the military I'm
not a high up whatever he's aircraft
control so there's certain levels of
clearance he told me that they would see
things that could not that yeah these
are like trained you know people it's
not just some random uh jerk on the
street is someone jerking High office he
would say they would see things on their
radar that they could not explain all
the time and this was very understood
for both sides and it wasn't
technological it was like okay this
doesn't make sense radar Distortion I
think is talking plasma or other stuff
like it right lightweight drones also
meta materials things like Aero gel um
airloy like hardcore machine material
that's lighter than air they would float
in the air yeah but okay stuff in the
vaccine is remember oh what what is it
graphene oxide yeah that stuff
and it can take any shape right graphene
it's hexagonally like honeycomb lattice
Adam thick the world is wrong you can
turn it into like you can make like uh
tubes out of it yeah it can take any
shape I mean hypothetically I don't know
if any shape is the right phrase because
Nano molecular level uh are you talking
about like a liquid metal yeah material
this is like Harley Quinn you see those
videos where the um graphene is being
moved around magnetically okay or
something you're not getting the stack
I want to say something Michael Mouse
yes sir so it was um I think it was 2006
I had just stopped working at O'Hare
Airport in Chicago I had friends who
still worked there and they confirmed
this story to me
I had a friend who was uh I think he was
on his way to O'Hare I'd worked for
American Eagle Airlines a regional
Airline you can look up photos of this
the photo of the UFO exists there was a
gray
saucer shaped object that came down from
the clouds and hovered above O'Hare
above the United Express terminal which
I believe was the sea Gates I could be
wrong C or D and stayed there for a few
minutes and then shot straight up into
the clouds and punched a hole in it
leaving a hole with sunlight coming
through
and
apparently a pilot looked out and had
some like rudimentary old cell phone
with a picture he took a picture of it
somehow and the photo exists you can
Google it you can find the photo
people I knew who worked there said they
saw it people like these are on these
are regular guys right mid-40s they're
not superstitious they watch football
and they played Xbox they cared nothing
for this and they were like I don't know
what that was man and they've seen
things so they wouldn't go for something
normal and here's the crazy thing my
friend who was on his way to work said
on Mannheim Road right next to the
airport people stopped their cars in the
middle of the road got out and were
staring at it okay yeah and then we're
just like so what was it we don't know
what it was
but uh uh there's it's a famous UFO
story you can read all about it and I
had left so I didn't see any of it but I
so all I can say is hearsay I ask people
who are there and they said they saw it
and they couldn't explain it I was
talking to cash Patel who oh yeah the
defense department with Trump yes I
believe I was like do we have craft that
can go out into space and then go under
the ocean and he was like
can't tell you that one yeah and I was
like okay he didn't say yes so I didn't
say no he didn't say no and he looked at
me like I can't tell you yeah they're 50
years ahead of what we know yes
laboratory that was like 100 years ago
the stuff that he was working I got to
point out people have posted a lot of
fake photos there's weird CGI garbage
and I wonder if it's intentionally
trying to shut the story down so here
let me pull this up right here this is
uh musings of an Explorer I just Googled
it and you can see this image which I
believe does look like the image I
remember I'm not sure and there's
something this is this is 2006 this is
before iPhones cell phones barely had
cameras they had really garbage cameras
and I don't know how the photo was taken
it says taking it O'Hare November 7
2006. I had just stopped working there I
think in like August and so my friends
people I knew were all still there I
called them I was like yo what is this I
heard this story crazy and uh there's
there's supposedly the image can I say
one thing just one sentence I want to
give a big Fu to Ashley Sinclair because
she told me to watch arrival and the
first two thirds of the movie awesome
and then the conclusion sucks so I
wasted two hours of my very short
remaining life so F you Ashley it was it
was so it was Seagate what arrival
arrival yeah it was Seagate which I
believe is United Express which was
right next to us so we I think we were D
and like H that was the American uh
American Eagle Gates so right across
would see United Express we never go
there that's their different company and
uh it was right above the seagates so
the craziest thing though and and you
know you read these stories and they say
12 employees saw it I'm like dude I had
a friend who worked there said the
people were getting out of their cars on
on in the middle of Manheim Road this
big you know uh State uh our local
highway and it's like that street lights
it's not like expression and let's talk
a bit of a misinformation so yeah it's
hanging around for a while for a couple
minutes for five minutes because like
there's people who said there was a book
that was published in France at the time
claiming that 9 11 never happened and
that the World Trade Center towers are
Holograms right so the point being if
you have any questions about these
issues right away there's enough
misinformation out there like oh oh so
you're saying that they're Holograms and
it was shot down by lasers so a lot of
times there's enough of this nonsense
that's flooded to make it seem that
anyone's asking about something you just
talked about where sane sober daylight
working class regular people are see our
eyewitnesses you could sweep it all in
the rug but just uh accusing it of being
the most extreme version because people
say no planes flew into not into the
yeah right yeah you know so this would
say that was CGI right this is what
bothers me about most conspiracy
theories is that they people who engage
in the most extreme thinking on an issue
actually make it impossible right to to
get to the bottom of an issue and so
I'll give you an example when the emails
got released by Wikileaks where uh uh
they started the whole pizza gate thing
someone said is it is it more what do
they say is it better to try uh uh play
dominoes on pizza or on pasta one day
seemingly out of nowhere someone
fabricated this idea that these words
were references to children they were
not now there are certainly CP is a
reference thing cheese pizza was a
reference thing but they conflated this
and you know what I think it really was
what drugs yes no no I'll say one more
thing Tim it was clearly not pizza it
was clearly called for something and we
don't know what that is and then what
happens pizza for an hour right yeah
heroin ecstasy no but it's not Pizza
Point is it's not right but so here's
the issue what's something that is
entirely believable is that a bunch of
White House people were doing hardcore
schedule one drugs like cocaine at a
party and they speak in code anemic yes
that could be we could easily
investigate drug abuse and say we want
to get to the bottom of what they were
talking about doing but then all of a
sudden the internet blows up with the
most insane conspiracies and then
immediately the media says this proof
it's fake and regular people don't
question it I'm going to say one I think
they do do that all the time but here's
the thing I don't think it's that that
insane because very publicly this
Administration killed a bunch of kids
overseas and no one even had a demotion
for it
in Afghanistan they're like oh we just
killed a bunch of kids up too bad no one
got reprimanded so I you can't think
it's too crazy that people in government
are literally killing children all the
time no no well everything that I've
said that my children I have five
children everything I've said for the
last 20 years they go godmother you and
your they call you mother
when they're pissed god mother you and
your ridiculous conspiracy theories
everything I said has came true three
years later okay every single everything
yeah when I said it was a pedo Ponzi
priesthood pyramid scheme yeah it's all
true it's coming true every day well in
four months we'll see if uh if the
tribunals happen but why are you in on
the bet Tim no I'm a pet sitter all
right I want to talk about a little bit
about anti-gravity because cut the
stream it's a wrap you end on the high
note there's a lot of muddied water on
anti-gravity that it's impossible you
know obviously it's totally impossible I
think it is and there's something called
the Bible by field Brown effect if you
want to look into like something that
might potentially be uh asymmetrical
capacitor thrusters and I'm wondering if
I try and do these experiments with
Jeremy riss at his laboratory in New
Jersey and we were trying to figure out
if you can increase horizontal velocity
fast enough you'll reduce Vertical
Velocity to zero and then you'll be you
won't be interacting with gravity net so
you'll be falling forward basically
overcome gravity no they don't
the UFO is overcoming gravity right now
yeah there's also something called
ionic wind which might be you able to
use to push metal or super lightweight
metal around how do we fund a buddy
comedy where they're both cops who have
to work together you're like rush hour
before we should do it hey do you
understand the words that are coming out
of my mouth now hold on hold on let me
let me say this Laboratories Ian
mentioned Arrow gel do you know what
Arrow gel is no I don't it's a solid
that's lighter than air and or I don't
think it's completely out of there it's
it's it's not lighter but it floats you
can like it's it's a solid and you can
like tap it it will like and it's super
heat resistant you can hit it with like
blow torches and this has been created
or it's hypothetical oh they have Arrow
graphite is lighter than air
so seven times lighter than air it is
lighter than a graphene Arrow gel it is
that graphene that's what I'm talking
about yeah this is we're going to start
pulling it out of the carbon dioxide and
then we're going to have to figure out
how not to pull too much out because
we're competing I think I hear wedding
bells let's have babies
you ready for number six
take a look maybe maybe we can find him
I'm not so sure it's lighter than there
because if it was lighter except that
it's fast it's lighter would hit the
space yeah it would float it would float
to the top out of the atmosphere right
so uh I don't know if they show but
anyway it exists um
veritasium has a video on it so here's
my point yeah there it is what about
rods from God do you know about that yes
that's right that was thorium the amount
of tungsten rods the um the uh is it or
is it Palladium but the the amount of
energy required to get that into space
just is you're storing the energy and
then you have to maintain it wait what
are these rods from Gods it's a
hypothetic theoretical weapon where we
launch uh a Tungsten Rod into space and
then keep it in orbit and when you
release it it's ten times more power 100
times more powerful than a nuclear bomb
Oh okay because gravity just fast but
you have to use the same amount of
energy to get into space then you have
to use energy to maintain its orbit so
people say it's not really feasible
Arrow
well being a solid suppose you can make
like you know Ian mentioned graphene
Aero gel suppose you can actually make a
super strong structure and then put
components in it so it's now basically
an airboat
yeah so with with an airplane with a jet
you have wings you an airfoil creates
lower pressure on the top higher
pressure on the bottom causing it to
lift right uh or I don't know I'm not an
expert on flight but uh if if when we
look at these UFOs it could just be a an
ultra light solid which can hold weight
and then actually displace enough air so
that it's hard for it to go down and
then uses standard thrust to move about
pretty quickly Bingo that's what I think
they are wait wait wait real quick sorry
something that really blew my mind I
never considered until I played Horizon
forbidden West do you know this video
game no I don't it's uh I was watching
arcanoid okay hold on oh great game and
forbid Western video games where it's a
post-apocalyptic world the world's been
re-terriformed so spoiler alerts old
game but something I never considered in
the new game the character fights a guy
who has a force field Shield after
defeating him she takes the shield and
she jumps off buildings activating it
and Glides with it cool and then I
realized if force fields existed
humans could just fly using the force
field because it's weightless and
displaces matter the idea that you have
a shield that weighs nothing you'd
parachute down and it would be
weightless that's crazy theoretically if
the force field could extend wide enough
you would not fall it's a lot like oh
just you go right in the water the boat
has areas we're sitting in a room with a
rock star so does hearing all this geek
talk make you like is this like garlic
to a vampire like
isn't this like the opposite of her
being a rock star talking all this geek
stuff no no no no no no no
nowadays nowadays the the backstage it's
all nerds on their computer like the
thicker the glasses the guitar player is
wearing the more likely it is that
you're gonna die in that pit and Phil
Phil was saying that backstage all the
time they're playing d d that's all they
did that kind of stuff yeah they're
Magic Gathering that does happen oh nice
that is
rock star stuff is vibrational and
frequency and like sound and all that
that's all that that's true that's a
good point yeah yeah physics yeah the
climatics it's where you you vibrate a
membrane with sand on it it'll take
these different patterns I got a
question what's your karaoke song
uh
uh oh
um mine's Baby Got Back nice one I like
that one
yeah my friend wrote a take off of that
called baby got front for girls
it's so funny
what's your karaoke song though oh um
Jake what's my karaoke song you
train them well there you go
I can't remember oh Cowboy sweetheart oh
okay I like that what's yours Michael uh
probably take me home tonight oh it's a
good song
Eddie Money oh I love Eddie Money he's
so good I think I'm gonna go plush by uh
Stone Temple Pilots I like hitting those
high notes oh this this is more off
topic I don't have one oh exactly look
at you look at me like I can't believe
we're having this coming
emotions foreign
I was just singing that because I just
saw Bohemian rhaps okay yeah yeah and
that song's so good it is the best song
ever do you go into doesn't it go into
another song they always play like the
two back to back it's We Are the
Champions and
We Will Rock You yeah what was it like
he doesn't say of the world in the end
that was a a that was a version that was
made for the credits of like the Mighty
Ducks or something oh everybody
everybody always yeah everybody always
sings of the world and yeah something
like that but it's not actually in the
original song it's in like a remake oh
something like that okay I could be
wrong we're gonna go to super chats yeah
before we do you guys can ask about
karaoke finish up this metaphor about
your boat in the air Theory because if
you vacuum out a really strong piece of
metal then it becomes you have the
vacuum that's increasing how much
lighter it is yeah anyway we'll go
deeper like that all right everybody if
you haven't already Adam's in space we
have to talk about that would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you like it and head over to
timcast.com become a member because the
members only show will be coming up at
about 10 p.m over at timcast.com where
you as members get to call in and ask
questions of us and our guests Alexa the
audience oh God that's death oh yeah
you're gonna love it all right here we
go God's other son says imagine going
back to 1990 and telling people that one
day Roseanne Barr would be better
looking than Madonna everyone said that
it was amazing all over the place
but it's true it's the truth
take the compliment did you know her
back in the day I did I met her a few
times she's a very nice older woman I
feel so sad that when people get oh
shade the shade
I caught that I love you so much I think
our artists are kind of I don't want to
derail too much but they're kind of like
they kind of speak for the for the
humanity you know like Chris Cornell
overdosing Prince overdosing it's like
horrific because our society has fallen
into that mess and to see Madonna a lot
of people want out of here you know part
of your way out yeah a lot of people die
young stay pretty yeah we have a very
very serious Super Chat d99 said 99 Ted
says we had someone try to get our
chickens today Tim always warned us I
just didn't think it would be this soon
but really some people steal chickens
yeah of course but what I what I'm what
I'm how much does a chicken cost like a
couple of bucks
a layer a hand that can lay eggs 20
bucks maybe more these days baby chicks
are a couple dollars
um but it could be like 20 bucks I had
Japanese I had all sort of uh un kind of
variety of chickens I had some did you
see you in I know I got un U.N you know
a variety of countries yeah yeah okay
okay that's what chicken city is
basically we've got like uh uh we have a
Polish Rooster here's Luke we named him
after Luke because Luke's polish you
know he's got a crazy haircut but they
they can cost a couple hundred bucks oh
yeah oh yeah fancy breeders of course
fancy breeds and the bigger ones and
stuff but uh when I get a black one
what's the black Japanese silky what is
it called uh we have we I think we do
have I don't like they have black meat
uh we don't have those we have the
silkies they have blue meat okay we do
have the all black chickens okay they're
complete even their eyes and their feet
and everything and then we get green
eggs we do get green eggs from a couple
of our Easter I think they're Easter
records but then we have um Jersey
Giants and they're they're black
chickens and they're huge very big and
then we have a Brahma we have a Brahma
boy see you know Roberto I think Roberto
and Sarah had a baby and she's a problem
he's right on red so but uh I was
warning people is that when Society
collapses
you'll be in your house and you'll hear
rustling and you'll run out to the
backyard and see some dude in a flannel
shirt suspenders with a handlebar
mustache grabbing one of your chickens
just like Charles crying and being like
I'm just so hungry and you'll be like
let Mike put my chicken down and these
Urban liberal hipsters who are starving
will be looting your farm for whatever
they can eat that's true
I caught all these uh Asian folk in my
yard over there in Hawaii I had Ducks
everywhere because I I should have
crushed their eggs but they were cute
well I ended up with about 40 ducks in
my back wow and here come all these
couple all Asian women with Nets still
my ducks and then my son says oh you
know Mom they work the hail in that
Chinese restaurant over there they were
really stealing your Ducks yeah they're
cooking
I'm not in Hawaii no Hawaii like there's
all kinds of why like there's wild
chickens everywhere yeah no but
migratory birds are federally protected
I'm pretty sure not in Hawaii
they're not they're not protected
domesticated Ducks that's what I'm
saying if they were just Ducks randomly
laying in there yeah I guess they're not
gonna be migratory yeah
so you know I'm like that's cool they're
just what let's like I wanna I got it as
an important one from Patricia Swisher
Michael what's on your shirt
[Music]
he's that uh he's that guy who got found
buck naked doing drugs in the hotel he's
the guy that likes to party yeah on
second thought someone should have
stopped him yeah yeah there you go
someone should have at least said pump
the brakes
see I don't know if I can take your
Biden pick seriously for president
because you said you wanted a Biden I
said but I had a cat there's a big
caveat he said Biden with a huge
Republican but you also already said he
had to have one I said by Dan from
Pennsylvania to be his VP uh fetterman
yeah
absolutely answer for uh our president
hey
pressure and they went yeah
I'm like what is going on
what is this it's it's scary what about
the fact that person of the year was a
uh High School Dropout who's like
mentally ill Gretta tunberg and
everyone's oh my God she's so smart like
how privileged do you have to be to say
I'm not going back to school until
everyone on Earth changes the weather
for me I hate it so much I hate her too
I don't think she's not mentally ill
though you're on Christian she had
selective mutism she didn't talk to
anyone developmentally disabled okay I
I'll take that correction no no because
I think mental illness refers to
specific ailments and developmental
disabilities I I'll accept that that
correction I always say that very
seriously too because people will see a
video of a socialist and they'll be like
they're mentally I'm like no no no no no
no being wrong isn't a mental illness
people who are developmentally disabled
or who are indoctrinated are not
mentally ill their brains work just full
of wrong information right and all for
people I meant I have mentality what
people don't understand is that under
Tim's beanie there's no top of the skull
it's just like the pulsating brain
most of my friends are there is
something particularly interesting about
the uh uh I tweeted something about the
said Greta tunberg with her you know let
me pull up the Tweet because I think I'm
gonna find that that perfect answer
mentally ill though no they're evil
that's not the same oh yeah you're right
I keep forgetting that one they're
definitely okay I think I think they're
very smart it's like Hollywood where
they when you pimp out your kid it's the
same exact thing yeah you've seen it
plenty of that in your lifetime I'm sure
I said something like with her zero
years of a oh here we go here we go
uh I'm just I'm just gonna read it I
said Greta is one of the most widely
cited climate scientists with over zero
years in the field and is staggering
zero degrees in diplomas Beyond grade
school Greta has taken the World by
storm with her cursory knowledge skimmed
from Google and rhetoric overheard from
activists yelling in the street
and then and then this is in April on 4
20. The Amazing Atheist says cool bro
what's your degree again you're a
political commentator I'm like quite
literally yes I don't go to climate
meetings and tell people how to change
the weather I just retweeted the
fetterman clip it's two seconds to pick
up my Twitter if you want I feel bad
time I know five days ago he's on Time
Magazine so and it's a out of the
darkness the untold story of severe of
Senator John fetterman's battle with
depression so you put a guy with severe
depression and mental health incapacity
in and then you make an article about
how much he's suffering now that he's in
like why did you even do that in the
beginning people that's what I want to
know I am not going to have you sit here
and Bash sadism
there is a lot of joy in seeing other
people suffer I assure you and all kinds
of Joy if you know what I mean let's
let's read this one uh Jacob Furman says
commenting on last night listen to
recent Jordan Peterson on Bill Maher and
jbp said something like Beauty and the
Beast is the archetypal pornographic
fantasy for women when will you get
either of them on the show writer's
strike was Mar uh has marfrino is that
Jordan Peterson and said that you're not
going to be able to get beast on the
show he's very hard to get he's secluded
which one X-Men or uh Disney yeah uh but
wait did Jordan Peterson really say that
but it makes a lot of sense being
because the girl dates the guy who's
like an animal and then she civilizes
him so it is like 50 Shades of Gray yeah
oh wow that's what he means it's not uh
too hard to wrap your head he civilizes
him she does though like he he goes from
a beast to like this proper gentleman
that's why I wanted to talk about a
story we didn't get to because someone
super chatted it that someone made a mod
for Skyrim where you can actually speak
to a companion use and that that's been
programmed with chat GPT to respond to
you in in words in English in real time
some like a like a Siri equivalent so uh
it's well beyond that but I mean like
it's like her like that with that right
yeah you're playing Skyrim and you have
a companion and you say where do you
think we should go and then your
companion says I don't know maybe we
should go to Castle Run or else yeah no
I remember Whiterun so I was talking
about this earlier the the AI apocalypse
is here we are a few years away from
seamless AI realities where you can talk
to people and they can store memories
you were mentioning calling them on the
phone yeah when not when you log out of
the game you can just give them a call
any time of day and be bond with that
NPC I'm gonna say something else I think
I don't think this is very controversial
chat chat GPT then it's gonna be ironic
what I'm about to say Chad gbt is more
articulate than the average person
of course but I mean that's that's
that's that's a big deal but then you
can really stay in your psychotic case
it's great and I love it I never leave
the house how many how many people do
you think will choose to live in the
fake World they choose it now yeah like
90 watching the show very kind of in
effect
here's uh Michael would you choose to
live in fake reality
no why not because my life is pretty
awesome yeah it's right now what about
some short fat incel who can't get a job
hey don't bring me into this well that
sucks oh wait I have a joke let me see
this I would choose to live here I got a
joke hey did you guys hear that Roseanne
Barr is launching an airline all the
flights already canceled
are happy in their lives is kind of the
point you're getting people but if you
have that option of going into the
Matrix or whatever like what about the
people that never get the chance to make
their lives into something that's that
they would choose over the Matrix here's
what what what's going to happen is
conservatives are for for several
reasons are overwhelmingly likely not
going to choose the fake reality one
they're more likely to have families and
I'll abandon them they're more likely to
be good looking and get and make more
money for Michael who says his life is
pretty awesome he wouldn't abandon that
yes but for the average person they
would say I'm happier and I'm special in
my own world well you know yeah but then
if you get to old people like 70 and
above such as myself hell yeah I'd
choose a living artificial world yes
everyone go on YouTube you're right in
one sentence you're right during covid
people who were low status had the
opportunity to increase their status by
berating and dominating other people who
weren't following the rules so we see
very clearly they would love to be in
this fake reality where they matter more
than they matter in real life and so
what happens then in the real world
policy will be set by those who are not
in fake worlds so conservatives and
Libertarians people who are successful
and more attractive will be in base
reality living their lives like normal
controlling government and people who
are weaker less skilled are going to
retreat to fake realities well that's
good then and at the very top is going
to be the anarchist so I hope you guys
are nice to me because I got those I
can't finish that sentence would you so
glitch said the reason I brought this up
to shout out glitch for the Super Chat
the simulation is broken it is creating
a new simulation inside of itself you
will be in the Pod inside the Pod yeah
I mean I would go into a pot to go into
the Matrix but I would come back out I I
get we get concerned when people forget
they're in a matrix when they're in
there that so we need you need like some
sort of so many people don't have self
self-awareness or introspection that's
not a common thing it's surprisingly
rare so like what they see is real one
percent yeah right what they see it's
like you know Cesar Millan always says
dogs don't think they react I like
proved in Psychology is that like a
known thing or is that just are you just
sensing that or it's just according I'm
quoting I'm quoting Caesar Millan The
Dog Whisperer that's who won his quotes
the people react the dogs don't think
they react and I'm saying people are the
same Jonathan height has a concept uh
the elephant and the rider so the
elephant is your emotional reaction and
the writer is like irrational brain yeah
you can kind of dick like kind of
suggest to an elephant where to go but
if the elephant doesn't want to go where
the rider directs the elephant's not
going there yeah you know and so the the
writer is really more just like PR your
elephant which is your your limbic
system and your emotional reaction
action and stuff your your elephant just
goes and does what it wants to do and
then your your Consciousness essentially
rationalize it and just it basically
tells the pr as to why you did it even
though it's actually more of a a
reaction than anything you ever thought
I was doing tricep curls and I was like
dude
it was I was doing maybe it was a poll I
was doing I was pulling I was pulling on
the road yeah and like this like pulling
down like this and after the fourth one
I was like uh I was Wheeling my body but
nothing was moving it didn't even hurt
like that's the rider telling the
elephant to turn right but he was like
it's lactic acid build up you can't even
yeah your muscles aren't responding
anymore then you should lower the weight
don't do vanity lifts he just stopped me
at four after that he's like you hit
your max that's the key you go up until
you can't do it anymore that's the key I
want to read this one demoralize
exemplifying everything that I and
others have said about DeSantis
supporters says so DeSantis finally did
what you've been demanding of him firing
bad staffers that hurt your feelings are
you finally going to praise him now like
you promised you would boy
that's going to get to Santa's some
support this is exactly my point Thank
you for for proving my point and
exemplifying the exact issue when this
is on a red is her feelings are you an
idiot it's not that I don't care what
he's saying hurt feelings saying hurt
feelings is an attempted emotional
yes it's meant to uh yeah
why would I support DeSantis after that
so my first assumption is this guy must
hate DeSantis and desperately want to
get influential personalities and shows
to turn onto Santas but DeSantis didn't
say anything bad to me you did
so then I have to wonder like is it
intentional sabotage unfortunately there
were uh members of descent as his own
staff who were insulting me as well so I
think it's just the Santa supporters are
incapable of of formulating responses
that will actually help the man win and
DeSantis is incapable of leading his
staff and his followers in helping him
win I'm gonna say one more thing uh I I
am I know a lot of people on the
DeSantis team as do you and I invited
one who I met with in person on my show
several times I only do deferential
interviews I don't even push back and
they just left me on red they refused
they refused I'm like this is an hour
for you to have a commercial for your
candidate I would not even be
antagonistic in the slightest what do
you mean on red that just didn't say
anything and the same thing my so I
don't know I don't do booking we have uh
for culture Awards Lisa Reynolds in for
for the show Cassandra handles booking
my understanding is that the Santa's
people will not come on this show and
we've been like can we get someone who
supports tennis to come on and have this
conversation and they're just they're
terrified they're buried in it already
it's weird to be terrified because you
are not going to be like you're gonna
have a very civil and give them an
opportunity to change your mind and they
can't I don't understand that so the
issue money on the table hey Rhonda
Sanders lacks Charisma there's no answer
how do you respond to that other than
we're working on it but it makes him
sound bad so you say something like jazz
jazz Jennings received trans surgery
while Rhonda centers was governor
there's been no addressing it directly
the answer is actually really simple Ron
DeSantis did what he could and he passed
laws that's fair instead they just
started tweeting at me that I was stupid
I was a I was wrong they lied well
both could be true sure but this is the
point instead of being like hey man look
we're really working on it they started
just dog piling on me that makes no
sense to me if they want them to lose
I'm just saying this doesn't make sense
to me because like I know enough about
PR that'd be very easy to say what you
just said right or or send you a
one-pager goes this is what Rhonda
santis did to combat this issue in
Florida and this is what Trump hasn't
done and just put it Forward instead
they said what an idiot Tim pulls a
he doesn't understand how laws
work they said Rhonda Sanders doesn't
have a time machine and he can't fly to
New York and change the laws and I'm
just like
huh I was like why are you all tweeting
at me instead of just saying like
here's a link to a story and being like
we're linked to press release yeah it's
so it's it's just they have no idea how
to handle
any of this the other thing too is like
you mentioned the polarization where
it's like if you oppose tennis you're a
trump supporter quite literally uh a
prominent personality tweeted I just
can't get behind DeSantis after this he
has he like he doesn't know how to
handle his campaign as PR and so they
immediately said why won't you address
Laura Loomer and Alex brucewoods and
it's just like I'm talking about
DeSantis that's an entirely different
campaign in different people if all you
can do in response to bad PR is point to
someone else I'll say okay great you're
both bad next question yeah
but thanks thanks for for the comment I
I gotta say I do believe some of these
people are actually just trying to sync
DeSantis like yeah posts like this do
nothing but get us saying negative
things about his campaign so why how
many people that were working for Trump
did that yeah that's a good point that's
a great Point Roseanne that's how they
are like I think that so many of people
on the right are just Democrats in
Disguise yeah
all right ptb says we're gonna we're
gonna have to start a Roseanne was right
jar yeah all right it's four months four
months I'll match it then we'll give it
to charity or somebody who needs it if
yeah the end of the year so we have to
December 31st yes to be fair or to
January if by you know January 1st at
midnight okay
and then the election next year
and so so after that we should have a
follow-up or something yeah and and then
you know what are you gonna do with the
money it would be a great excuse for you
to come back to Austin
why don't we do an event at like a venue
and we'll and we'll uh we'll call it the
Roseanne was wrong there were no
military tribes
no no we'll call it Roseanne on trial
and we could even do a little roast
because in the event the tribunals do
happen it's gonna be good to have the
event ready to talk about it you know
what let's raise money for was it called
rain which is for kids who have uh had
to deal with uh child abuse so that is
something I think is a really big issue
that isn't talked about enough and it's
too politicized I love her I don't know
who's in charge I could be getting the
name wrong but let's talk it might have
to be like second or third week of
January point being like let's use it to
raise money for like a cause that's
everyone agrees with is a problem yeah
sounds good have you seen the sound of
Freedom no not yet oh man you will do
you think Rogan's venue is probably
totally booked and he just he wouldn't
he only doesn't do it you think so yeah
but there's lots of places in Austin and
there's another one down the street
that'll let us do it too comedy combine
them yeah comedy Mothership would be
okay
but we're not really there would it
would be a comedy element it should be a
trick it's not it's it's not comedy like
like law that it has to be comedy shows
at his Club no I can't do whatever yeah
yeah well we can have Comics they may be
broke down it's like funny stories
probably booked up get you I don't know
Dave Smith ask him and Louis Gomez no
they want comics
no you have not failed podcast
uh but maybe maybe we actually do we'll
bring some some Comics that'll be
terrific we could have a political
comedy kind of thing a roast have you
been roasted before yeah Comedy Central
it's hilarious go watch it is it fun or
does it suck it's a uh it's so fun
you can't wait to hear what they're
going to say the thing that I found with
people who are at like were famous they
P everyone's scared to make fun of them
but she's a comedian right so if you're
cracking jokes at her she's peeing her
pants but everyone's scared to do it so
there were some good no no I'm talking
about the general pants you're not
you're what people I learned about being
friends with you is you're surprised I'm
much more pretentious than you are and
you but you're in a position to be so if
people make jokes with you you laugh or
you say that's not funny but you're not
offended no I love a good job no matter
who it's at so let's we'll try and
figure it out yeah we'll start yeah but
you guys are all gonna you know be all
in the money telling you uh-huh
it'll writes a check and hands it to you
yeah yeah it will be funny because at
least she knows what a check is I want
Roseanne to be right but I I don't think
that I think that uh you're gonna be
paying up hold on wait wait hold on hold
on clarification Michael what if the
military what if the Military Tribunal
is for Trump officials that she wins
okay any Military Tribunal at all I mean
it's got to be like large scale it's not
like one guy's in a military trip you
know that's that happens every day
anyway that's gotta be yeah okay you
know it's got to be uh public on TV yeah
public and on TV and it's Gotta Be let's
trust him to be the judge to see who
wins if it's a gray area Okay because
you're I mean I'll call the audience and
ask sure that's fair too you're on the
fence tribunals period yeah that means
there's a three or multiple judges
military tribute Twitter judges at least
their military it's a Military Tribunal
which is different from uh you know
Department of Justice trial but it has
to be three judges I think for the try
but they try and tribunal I think so I
don't know at least three judges
it's three officers of of uh I believe
you found the spoke General rank
I want to read this uh Rusty racing
there's three zeros in a thousand
dollars that you're gonna be giving me
exactly
put no money in no you
Rusty razor super chatted us saying
around 1996 researchers from the
University of Alabama at Huntsville
created a Bose Einstein Insight that
canceled gravity above it the story is
in pop mechanics and Pops or Pop's eye
the researchers disappeared they
disavowed their work years later so they
reappeared
the Bose Einstein condensates an
interesting phenomenon that I have very
little information about
well you better get busy yeah that's the
God particle right do I have that right
no you're thinking of the um the Higgs
bosons that all sounds the same to me
Bose was a scientist that apparently
Einstein ripped off a lot like people
credit with Einstein with a lot of his
discoveries but like Bose was the actual
mathematician no Emily nether was a meth
but we'll grab another one
Toy News Daily says most likely in three
years every phone will come with an AI
assistant Siri 2.0 it'll do everything
personal assistant for anything you want
to do they kind of have some verses that
already somewhat well every what
everything you want to do we're we're
very close to the point where you'll
literally just call your phone by name
and the name is effectively a passcode
for Activation so it'll be like enter a
name an activation code and you'll say
like you know make reservations at
system 101 yeah yeah seven o'clock
reservations uh I might be late set it
up for me no one at the restaurant will
talk to anybody it'll be done yeah the
network will do it you'll show up and
then they'll say welcome
this is how it's going to be and yeah so
yet in 2023 we got to take calls from
the audience when when uh I was flying
back from Vegas on United they changed
my flight without telling me Oh from it
was uh Vegas to Houston to DC and then
at two in the morning with while I was
asleep it changed to Vegas to Denver to
DC
and from first class to coach oh my gosh
without a refund or anything so you know
that's that's gonna be fraud or
something and let me thank Roseanne
because because you've came here they
flew me first class so I feel like a big
shot today but uh uh because there were
no humans involved there were the
customer service was a robot robot
couldn't answer anything this is the
future I ordered me for McDonald's for
the first time I'd rather work with the
robot with them with the human you've
seen who's out there McDonald's there's
no humans I just ordered on a machine
and then they got my order the guy they
gave to me there never were hold on wait
we gotta read this one no no names try
to make it right yeah your way kinda no
name 99 no face 88 says Roseanne you are
awesome Tim you did good getting her to
come on I did oh my gosh
hahaha
I didn't even know she was coming
I was just sitting sitting Michael's
like I got a surprise he's all Gideon
laughing yeah that is a good Michael
impression that's fair
so excited and then Roseanne watching
she's like hi and I'm like oh it's a
Roseanne and then he's like oh I had a
whole speech she was gonna walk in
we had to get the picture for the fight
now we didn't
yeah uh well we have oh that was fun it
was fun to come yeah well I appreciate
it yeah uh we still have the members
only show it's in a few minutes but can
I go to the bathroom and smoke before we
do this yes
I don't know what you all are talking
about with games in this for young
people so all
recuse myself for a cigarette cigarettes
well so with that being said everybody
smash the like button if you haven't
already subscribe to the channel go to
timcast.com become a member we're going
to jump to the members only segment in
just a few minutes you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast Michael do you want to shout out
uh Michael malice on Twitter and uh the
white pill book I hope you all read it
and enjoy it it's why I'm hopeful for
the future of this country Roseanne do I
shout out your show before you oh yeah
the Roseanne Barr show wherever podcasts
are available I'm on the third and
roseannebar.com follow her on Twitter I
got her her real Twitter account back at
the real Roseanne yeah
and he helped me that's right chaos
demon nice work dude yeah
yeah that's correct got it good I am
filibonti the band is All That Remains
we are available on uh Apple music
Spotify YouTube that whole deal you go
to the bathroom right there every time
hi everyone I'm Ian Crossland follow me
at Ian crossland.net we're gonna make
some magic tonight good to see you
Rosanna I'll see you in a little bit
yeah dude I'm all about the gemstones
this is a ruby is that really Ruby it's
legit Ruby it's never uncut they make
rubies yeah they make rubies
got you a gem in Tijuana and Luke
charged it in the ocean oh good then you
need to get it yeah thank you sir all
right guys we'll uh see you on the after
show calendar uh yeah I am telling you
guys can follow me everywhere at Kellen
PDL I was gonna tell Roseanne that the
chat absolutely loved her tonight I was
laughing the whole time just reading
people's comments and everything but uh
yeah awesome show all right we'll see
you all over at timcast.com in a few
minutes thanks for hanging out